if you feel everyone's making 70k and  you're making 70k  why not share the equity company with  everybody why or 100 of it because  you're sitting there worth a couple  hundred million why not have them have a  few hundred thousand dollars of net  worth added to them  yeah  so it's because the  the the the shares  currently like we're not public like so  the shares aren't  you can't like go sell them you know  what i mean oh but you can give a uh  stock options where the individual can  invest over a five-year period and there  are a lot of people that work for  companies who are not public that give  shares that allows the individual to  build up their network because right now  your employees don't have a high net  worth you do so although you are being  very noble on the area of giving  everybody a 70 000 salary i'm thinking  if you're gonna go that why not go fully  and give everybody a piece of the  company so it's equally shared with  everyone